[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend die ampeln menschen im
berliner koalitionsbett haben es auch
heute geschafft den so lange vermissten
zauber eines anfangs am leben zu halten
nach der spd haben auch die grünen basis
vertreter heute koalitionsverhandlungen
genehmigt praktisch einstimmig die fdp
wird morgen wohl folgen so weit also so
gut thomas reichert übers vorangehen und
dann fragen an christian lindner es gibt
am ende ganz schön viele umarmungen viel
erleichterung so deutlich wird dass
grüne votum für koalitionsverhandlungen
aus nach drei stunden reden in denen es
kaum ein kritisches wort zum sondierungs
ergebnis gab es
ist wohl gelungen hoffnung zu wecken wir
sind in einer hoffnungs zeit angekommen
und jenseits der einzelnen punkte das
ist das große was in den letzten wochen
erzielt wurde eine hoffnungs zeit die
wir nicht enttäuschen dürfen nur zwei
gegenstimmen eine enthaltung die grünen
sind fest entschlossen nach 16 jahren
opposition sich die chance zu regieren
nicht entgehen zu lassen auch wenn es
bei vielen punkten jetzt erst konkret
und damit auch erst richtig schwierig
wird die freude ist ganz dämpfer aber
bei anderen setzen werden wir noch sehr
sehr hart verhandeln müssen auch beim
klimaschutz das ist jetzt das brett was
wir weiter bohren müssen in diesen
vorliegt
die grünen sind unter hohem
erwartungsdruck sie haben viel
versprochen jetzt müssen sie viel
liefern beim klima zuallererst aber kaum
einer zweifelt dass es irgendwie eine
einigung geben wird ich glaube jetzt
sind alle drei parteien der auffassung
dieses land muss regiert werden diese
gemeinsamkeit regieren zu wollen und
keine anderen kräfte zu sehen die es
kann zeigt führt dazu das ist ein sehr
hohen einigungsdruck gibt das größte
fragezeichen bleibt die finanzierung für
den versprochenen fortschritt olaf
scholz verrät heute in berlin direkt nur
so viel die ampel hofft auch auf private
investitionen in klimaschutz und wir
werden auch zusätzlich mittel mit
öffentlichen investitionen bereitstellen
müssen das ist auch geplant und ist auch
in der finanzplanung jetzt schon
vorgesehen es geht also darum die dinge
richtig zu kombinieren die fdp
entscheidet morgen über die aufnahme von
koalitionsverhandlungen aber den sekt
haben sie an der basis schon mal
aufgemacht zumindest den bad krozingen
im südwesten dafür dass fdp mitgliedern
eine ampel anfangs skeptisch sein
klicken sie hier erstaunlich
kompromissbereit jetzt ist ja doch
ziemlich viel von der fdp durchgesetzt
aber auch ich glaube den mindestlohn
muss man der spd lassen damit sind sie
in den wahlkampf gezogen wir müssen auch
nachgeben in verschiedenen punkten aber
es ist glaube ich unsere auch unsere
staatsmännischer staatsbürgerliche
pflicht eine regierung zu bilden das
möglichst schnell auch damit die bürger
sehen die politiker raufen sich zusammen
und kommen zu guten lösungen und ich
glaube das findet man schon
regierungspapier doch ganz gut
mindestens von südbaden aus betrachtet
kann also auch die fdp den weg frei
machen für koalitionsverhandlungen nach
der einigung im großen kann es dann
losgehen mit dem harten ringen ums
kleingedruckte
hartes ringen vielleicht hat man ja doch
am freitag ein bisschen zu viel harmonie
zu früh verbreitert guten abend herr
lindner guten abend herr kleber sehen
sie noch mögliche große brocken im weg
an denen das auch noch scheitern könnte
scheitern ist hier keine option wir
brauchen eine stabile regierung in
deutschland sie sollte auch schnell
gebildet werden das jetzt vorliegende
sondierungs papier ist dafür eine sehr
gute grundlage ich gehe so weit zu sagen
es ist eine chance die wir sie seit
vielen jahren in deutschland nicht
hatten um gesellschaft wirtschaft und
staat zu modernisieren und deshalb werde
ich morgen unseren gremien auch
empfehlen in koalitionsverhandlungen
einzutreten das müsste den relativ
leicht fallen wenn man sich diese zwölf
seiten durchliest muss man sagen die fdp
kommt ganz schön gut weg keine
steuererhöhungen ist da festgelegt kein
verstoß gegen die schwarze null
festgelegt keine abschaffung der
privaten krankenversicherung festgelegt
kein generelles tempolimit also die fdp
hat es irgendwie geschafft
kernforderungen in feste deutsche kurze
sätze zu packen während andere leute
ihre wünsche noch anstreben und
erreichen wollen und idealerweise kann
es so weitergehen
auch armin laschet und friedrich merz
haben in der tat dieses sondierungs
papier jahr gewürdigt das muss man
anerkennen wenn der amtierende cdu
vorsitzende und herr merz sagen das ist
ein gutes sondierungsergebnisse
uns geht es allerdings nicht nur darum
grenzen aufzuzeigen die liste die sie
gerade verlesen haben das sind ja dinge
die nicht kommen für uns ist wichtig
dass auch dinge kommen ein klimaschutz
der auf technologie basiert den wollen
wir wollen in diesem sinne den umbau
unserer wirtschaft dafür schneller ein
haken herr lindner weil sie bei unseren
freunden in der ard heute abend gesagt
haben es wird ein
klimaministerium geben das auf augenhöhe
ist mit dem finanzministerium fast mit
dem kanzleramt so haben sie es genannt
davon sehe ich in den zwölf seiten
nichts ist das tatsächlich vereinbart
worden nein es ist meine erwartung meine
erwartung ist dass es natürlich beim
klimaschutz der eine solche priorität
hat ein ministerium gibt der sich
federführend darum bemüht aber
keine keine bereits bestehende
verabredung wenn sie gestatten nehme ich
den punkt von gerade noch auf rang acht
und haben deswegen raus und dahinter und
was ganz wichtig ist dafür nachweisen
dass gar nichts passiert
heute wenn ich das darauf gleich kommen
kann es nichts verpassen wir das am ende
heute etwas eigenartiges passiert die
juso-vorsitzende hat gesagt aus ihrer
sicht sei dieses papier finanzpolitisch
nicht solide genug also mit anderen
worten die jusos werfen der fdp
loses umgang mit finanzen vor das hatte
ich noch nie gesehen aber sie hat einen
punkt das ist tatsächlich noch nichts
konkret gesagt dass er das 500
milliarden euro irgendwie aufgetrieben
werden müssen allein für die klima
lösungen also wir halten kurz fest die
positiven dinge die möglich sind konnte
ich jetzt hier heute nicht aufzählen bei
bildung sozialstaat einem einstieg in
eine generationengerecht finanzierter
rente aber ich komme jetzt auf ihren
punkt der finanzen zu sprechen es gibt
zwei klare leid entscheidungen keine
höheren steuern und das einhalten der
schuldenbremse
wir werden innerhalb des haushalts auch
spielräume suchen müssen um notwendige
vorhaben zu finanzieren aber und das ist
ein stück handschrift der fdp fraglos
wir wollen die rahmenbedingungen für
private investitionen in deutschland so
stärken dass wir in den
zukunftsbereichen digitalisierung und
klimaschutz auch mit dem geld mit dem
kapital aus der wirtschaft dinge
erreichen können das ist in unserem land
bislang nicht in hinreichender weise
erfolgt das ist aber möglich und da gibt
es auch in diesem sondierungs papier
passagen die gegenwärtig noch nicht
hinreichend öffentlich wahrgenommen
werden ich mache darauf aufmerksam wir
schreiben wir wollen privates kapital
auch dadurch aktivieren dass wir unsere
öffentliche förderbank nutzen um private
investitionen
auch öffentlich abzusichern dafür
braucht man nicht ein euro höhere
schulden auch nicht ein euro höhere
steuern sondern es nur ein
unternehmerisches agieren des staates um
dinge möglich zu machen wenn jetzt in
dem papier steht dass sie keine großen
und keine kleinen parteien mehr so ist
dass da tatsächlich drin wir sehen
gleichberechtigte partner auf augenhöhe
gilt das dann auch bei der verteilung
der ministerien oder kommen dann doch
die alten du bist größer als ich und du
bist kleiner als ich gespräche wieder
auf darüber ist noch nicht gesprochen
worden und ich rate auch ab darüber
öffentlich zu debattieren jetzt sind
noch viele sachfragen die davor geklärt
werden müssen brauchen sie dafür
tatsächlich noch so gut wie das
ausgegangen ist die zeit bis weihnachten
im moment wird ja immer gesagt bis
weihnachten haben wir das geschafft
ich will nicht immer neue termine in die
welt setzen das ist eine zeitangabe die
gewählt worden ist auch von herrn scholz
und ich will mich einfach jetzt an der
orientieren ich glaube es auch ein stück
sicherheit dass man bei den botschaften
die man einmal gesetzt hat zunächst
bleibt dank herr lindner und einen
schönen abend und eine gute woche ich
danke ihnen und
damit zu den nachrichten die sich
zunächst mit der demnächst ehemaligen
kanzlerin partei widmen
nach der wahlniederlage von cdu csu hat
auf dem deutschlandtag der jungen union
auch unions-fraktionschef brinkhaus die
partei auf einen neuanfang in der
opposition eingeschworen dafür brauche
es mehr zusammenhalt und loyalität
erklärte brinkhaus der auch als
möglicher bewerber für den cdu vorsitz
gilt künftig dürfe sich die parteien
nicht mehr nur von einer person abhängig
machen zugleich warf brinkhaus den ampel
sondieren einen strammen links kurs vor
mit beginn der korona krise war die zahl
der asylbewerber in der eu eingebrochen
jetzt steigt sie wieder deutlich
wichtigste ziel start für schutzsuchende
bleibt deutschland bis ende september
wurden hier rund 100.000 erstanträge
gestellt vor allem die zahl afghanischer
schutzsuchende hat sich wegen der krise
dort deutlich erhöht gut 15.000 stellten
seit anfang des jahres antrag auf asyl
in deutschland
seit sieben jahren demonstrieren
anhänger der pg der bewegung jede woche
in dresden
der protest dagegen bleibt aber ebenso
ungebrochen so formierte sich auch heute
wieder in dresden breiter widerstand
gegen päda bei einer kundgebung für
demokratie weltoffenheit und ein
friedliches miteinander
peggy gilt als rassistisch und wird vom
verfassungsschutz als extremistische
bewegung beobachtet
in ungarn sucht die opposition einen
gemeinsamen kandidaten der im kommenden
frühjahr gegen den langjährigen
regierungschef orban antreten soll
insgesamt sechs parteien organisierten
erstmals eine entsprechende vorwahl bei
der nach auszählung fast aller stimmen
der konservative kandidat peter morici
sei deutlich vorne liegt die unterlegene
kontrahentin dobrev von den
sozialdemokraten sagte ihm unterstützung
zu markey sei will umstrittene gesetze
von orban rückgängig machen und den euro
in ungarn einführen
60 jahre nach dem massaker an den
algerischen demonstranten in paris haben
dort heute hunderte eine umfassende
anerkennung des verbrechens durch den
französischen staat gefordert 1961 waren
eine bis heute nicht geklärte zahl von
algerien in paris von der polizei
getötet worden historiker sprechen von
mindestens 120 opfern außerdem waren
12.000 sogenannte muslimische franzosen
festgenommen worden die algerier hatten
für die unabhängigkeit ihres landes
demonstriert als erster präsident
frankreichs gedachte gestern abend
emanuel makro opfer
fabriken in aller welt fabriken aller
branchen wird gerade die luft
abgeschnürt bildlich gesprochen aber
nicht übertrieben was fehlt sind
halbleiter chips
unentbehrlich für alle produkte in die
elektronik verbaut wird also ein
großteil der industriellen wertschöpfung
der menschheit der engpass einer
einzigen produktklasse mangel an diesen
winzigen teilen es für die
weltwirtschaft so gefährlich wie früher
nur eine große prise mit auswirkungen
die jeder spürt und zwar jetzt schon
lücken in der ausstellungsfläche im
geschäft von harald rücken in
mönchengladbach er führt den
familienbetrieb seit 21 jahren eine
situation wie derzeit hat er noch nie
erlebt zu normalen zeiten verkauf ich
dem kunden das gerät was er braucht also
das modell nach wahl
das rufe ich ab am nächsten tag steht es
hier und wir stellen gerade fest dass
selbst die oder gerade die gängigsten
modelle die am häufigsten
gewünscht werden jetzt wirklich
vergriffen sind und das über monate der
mangel an halbleiterchips ist der
hauptgrund er betrifft nahezu alle
produkte in denen elektronik bauteile
verarbeitet sind besonders angespannt
ist die lage in der autoindustrie ohne
chips fährt kein auto ohne chips stehen
länder stellen bei opel in eisenach
beispielsweise bis zum jahresende
weltweit können in diesem jahr bis zu 11
millionen autos nicht produziert werden
davon allein in deutschland mehr als
eine million und auch die lkw produktion
wie hier bei daimler wird eingebremst im
dritten quartal und in den letzten
monaten wurde es herausfordernder was
wir tun ist dass wir teile vorübergehend
in einen lkw einbauen dann dieselben in
den nächsten lkw einsätzen nur um die
produktion am laufen zu halten um dann
möglichst schnell liefern zu können wenn
die fehlenden halbleiterchips eintreffen
der weltweite bedarf an halbleitern
steigt seit jahren und wird weiter
steigen sie steuern strom und
datenflüsse etwa in autos smartphones
haushaltsgeräten corona hat die
knappheit verstärkt durch home office
boom und einem putsch der
digitalisierung insgesamt dazu kommt
dass die weltweite logistik etwas aus
dem takt geraten ist es gab hafen
schließungen in china auch das hat dazu
beigetragen dass wir in dieser krise
sind hauptsächlich werden halbleiter
bisher aus asien importiert
ich denke eine lehre aus dieser krise
wird sein dass man sich wahrscheinlich
wirklich zu sehr auf die internationale
arbeitsteilung verlassen hat und jetzt
merkt man dass der weg vielleicht doch
zu einseitig war und dass man sich nun
alternativen überlegen muss mehr
halbleiterproduktion auch in europa eine
der lösungen bosch etwa hat kürzlich ein
werk in dresden eröffnet infineon im
österreichischen villach doch auch die
politik sei gefordert sagt der verband
der elektro- und digital industrie will
schnell ein förderprogramm der eu
da wird gerade dran gearbeitet und das
sollte dass weihnachten entschieden
werden und wir hoffen dass auch die neue
bundesregierung schnell dazu dann ihre
unterstützung gibt das zweite ist es
gilt weiter in die entsprechende
ausbildung zu investieren
kurzfristig wird das allerdings nicht
helfen der aktuelle halbleiter mangel
weiter bestehen mindestens bis 2022
vielleicht sogar länger er wird den
weltweiten aufschwung zumindest bremsen
und für wartezeiten und auch steigende
preise bei vielen elektronikprodukten
sorgen
dieser globale chip mangel zeigt gerade
auch wie abhängig europa ist von
entwicklungen die sehr weit weg
passieren scheinbar sehr weit weg der
wichtigste chiphersteller der welt ist
taiwan die insel provinz im norden des
südchinesischen meers die mao zedongs
commission kommunistische revolution
nicht erobern konnte die unter us
amerikanischen schutz steht und peking
erhebt jetzt immer militanter
anspruch auf dieses abtrünnige gebiet
wie sie es sehen wenn im pazifik ein
neuer kalter krieg auf zieht dann ist
taiwan sowas wie sein berlin ein
möglicher zündfunke mit viel größerer
bedeutung allerdings für die wirtschaft
der welt als berlin jemals war ulf
röller berichtet wie chinas
kommunistische partei erfolg auf eine
neue konfrontation einstellt
dieser film um die schlacht um ging
nicht zur zeit alle zuschauerrekorde in
chinas kinos es ist ein heldenepos aus
dem korea krieg in dem chinesische
soldaten das us-militär demütigen die
botschaft einfach steht auf kämpft gegen
amerika verteidigt unsere heimat
präsident ski lässt solche filme
produzieren um sein land in
nationalismus zu baden und auf den
großen konflikt mit den usa
einzuschwören im wahren leben geht es um
den konflikt der gegenwart es geht um
taiwan aus sicht pekings der abtrünnige
bruder die wiedervereinigung unseres
landes wird wirklichkeit werden
in den letzten zehn jahren sind chinas
rüstungsausgaben um 76 prozent auf
252 milliarden gestiegen sie ließ mitte
oktober schon mal die invasion taiwans
trainieren sie hält die vereinigten
staaten für angeschlagen innenpolitisch
zerstritten außenpolitisch nach dem
chaotischen afghanistan abzug blamiert
die chinesen glaube ich sie gewinne den
konflikt mit den usa denn die sind nicht
bereit wegen taiwan einen dritten
weltkrieg zu führen taiwan ist nicht
entscheidend für die us interessen
die usa halten gilt in large scale
access 20 21 heißt die militärübung in
diesem jahr die das
verteidigungsministerium
martialische in szene setzt
das ziel eine chinesische aggression im
indopazifischen mehr abzuwehren für die
us militärs ist die kriegsgefahr
gestiegen
die gefahr wird in den nächsten sechs
jahren sichtbar werden
taiwans präsidenten zeigen wenn weiß das
und rüstet auf das demokratische land
bereitet sich auf eine invasion vor und
sieht sich als neue verteidigungslinie
der freiheit gegen die mächtiger
werdende diktatur china
niemand soll sich der illusion hingeben
dass taiwanesische volk wird sich nicht
dem druck chinas beugen
eine erzwungene vereinigung würde den
appetit der kommunistischen partei
ein parteien diktatur in der region
auszuweiten
präsident sieht die wiedervereinigung
als historische mission er hat sie den
chinesischen volk versprochen hält er
wort dann könnte es krieg geben
zurück nach deutschland
es gab auch sport in diesem sonntag
bundesliga-fußball fall im spitzenspiel
der fußball-bundesliga hat bayern
münchen mit einem tor feuerwerk binnen
sieben minuten seine macht demonstriert
fünf zu eins ging die partie gegen bayer
leverkusen aus die bayern damit wieder
an der tabellenspitze leverkusen auf
platz drei und im zweiten sonntagsspiel
trennten sich der fc augsburg und
bielefeld 1 zu 1 unentschieden
auf der kanarischen insel la palma droht
ein zweiter lavastrom das meer zu
erreichen und eine neue landzunge zu
bilden so wie es bereits durch einen
ersten lavastrom geschehen ist die
landkarte la palmas verändert sich etwa
200 meter sei die heiße masse noch vom
wasser entfernt so das vulkanologische
institut der region dutzende neue
erdbeben auf der insel deuten laut
experten darauf hin dass der vulkan noch
einige zeit aktiv bleiben wird
herbst franziskus hat die jüngsten
gewalttaten in norwegen großbritannien
und afghanistan verurteilt der weg der
gewalt führe zu einer niederlage für
alle weil gewalt stets neue gewalt
hervorrufen so das katholische
kirchenoberhaupt im norwegischen
kongsberg wurde bei einem gottesdienst
der opfer des anschlags vor vier tagen
gedacht auch mitglieder der norwegischen
königsfamilie nahmen teil am mittwoch
hatte ein däne in kongsberg fünf
menschen getötet darunter auch eine
deutsche
das buch das claudio armbruster uns
vorstellt hat eine vorgeschichte das
leben eines journalisten der sich selbst
seine freiheit die zukunft seiner
familie seiner redaktion seiner zeitung
aufs spiel setzen muss um das zu tun
wofür er journalist geworden ist die
wahrheit zu berichten wann immer möglich
die machenschaften der mächtigen
aufzudecken und das hat er getan das
regime des präsidenten erdogan hat sich
dafür bitter gerächt und tut es weiter
dieser journalist kann denn da liegt
jetzt eine einzigartige erdogan
biografie vor in eine graphic novel
gepackt die erdogan gerecht werden soll
und das tut sie tatsächlich wenn ihnen
freunde jetzt waren das könnte doch
verständnis wecken für diesen mann
erinnert denn da an seinem prinzip
journalisten machen keine kampagnen sie
sagen was ist und was war hier in einem
gezeichneten buch
[Musik]
drei fragen drei mal warum warum eine
erdogan biografie warum als graphic
novel also als comic und warum
ausgerechnet von ihm kann denn da
warum ich nun traditionalist bin und
schriftsteller
weil erdogan eine wichtige figur ist und
weil er der typ ist der mein leben
zerstört hat und mein land
es hat auch etwas mit verantwortung zu
tun dass ich das geschrieben habe
es gibt viele bücher über erdogan aber
ich wollte etwas neues ausprobieren und
graphic novel
zwei jahre hat er daran gearbeitet
gemeinsam mit dem ägyptischen künstler
und karikaturisten mohammad an war auch
eher wieder ein regime gegner der seine
heimat verlassen musste zwei jahre
recherche fakten checken und zeichnen
war als linker politik
ich glaube als politische karikaturisten
lieben wir diese art von riskanten job
sein aber es ist auch wichtig zu zeigen
wie sich menschen verändert vom
fußballspieler zum diktator das ist die
kernaussage unserer grafik machen
das buch schaut weit zurück in erdogans
kindheit in armut
beten und fußball spielen der strenge
vater
die anfänge in der politik der große
redner erdogan seine zeit im gefängnis
und sein weg zur macht
dündar zeigt auch erdogan stärken seinen
willen sein durchhaltevermögen
verständnis
ja das war eine herausforderung und
diese möglichkeit bestimmt um ehrlich zu
sein meine frau hat mich schon deswegen
gewarnt wenn man sieht dass er in seiner
kindheit leiden musste versteht man ihn
besser hat vielleicht sogar verständnis
gab
aber das ist teil seiner geschichte das
darf ich nicht ausradieren ich
porträtiere ihn so wie er ist
welche reaktionen erwartet er vor allem
aus der türkei
das größte lob für mich wäre ja sie sind
sein gegner aber sie sind immer noch ein
objektiver journalist
glauben sie erdogan wird es lesen
hoffentlich das ist die große frage ja
eigentlich hasst er es zu lesen er hasst
schriftsteller und ganz besonders hasst
er karikaturen comics und humor nun
dieses buch ist ein comic von dem
schriftsteller den allermeisten hast und
es geht um ihn ich bin sicher er liest
es nachts
heimlich
ein 300 seiten comic da muss man erst
mal durch aber dieses buch ist aus zwei
gründen interessant weil man durch das
lesen und sehen ahnt warum erdogan der
wurde der er ist und
wann denn das geschrieben hat
aufklärung mit bildern und worten das
buch kommt nächste woche in die
geschäfte das war also in dieser
richtung schon ein erster einblick in
unseren sonntäglichen ausblick auf das
was kommt
[Musik]
am dienstag wird in frankfurt am main
die buchmesse eröffnet nach der reinen
online ausgabe im letzten jahr sollen
sich in kleinerer form verlage autoren
und leser wieder leibhaftig begegnet
25.000 besucher am tag werden
eingelassen alle anderen können
veranstaltungen online und im fernsehen
verfolgen natürlich auch auf den kanälen
von zdf und 3sat
am donnerstag werden sich in brüssel
staats und regierungschefs zum
eu-gipfeltreffen um unter anderem über
maßnahmen gegen die hohen energiepreise
und über klimapolitik zu beraten
parallel dazu ebenfalls in brüssel
werden die nato-verteidigungsminister
tagen nach dem überhasteten abzug aus
afghanistan werden antworten gesucht wie
weiter am hindukusch und wie weiter mit
dem bündnis
am freitag wird in oslo das neue edvard
munch museum eröffnet der bau im neu
entstandenen kultur viertel amt york
bietet viel platz für das werk des
überaus produktiven malers sein
bekanntestes bild der schrei ist bereits
wohlbehalten im neuen quartier
angekommen
und das wetter in dieser oktoberwoche
wird herbstlich ab mittwoch auch
stürmisch morgen scheint nach auflösung
der nebel und hochnebelfelder oft die
sonne nur im nordosten bleibt es trüb in
küstennähe regnet es zwölf bis 19 grad
im dauernebel kälter am dienstag ziehen
von westen regenwolken auf dann wird es
überall unbeständig am mittwoch und
donnerstag zeitweise stürmisch am
mittwoch mit 16 bis 23 grad
außergewöhnlich mild
so marietta slomka und heinz wolf
arbeiten am morgen hier vorne wir gehen
mal in den hintergrund und wünschen
allen eine gute zeit und sagen bis bald
[Musik]